Imagínense parados en una playa,
mirando al océano;
las olas rompen contra la costa
y un azul que se extiende al infinito.
Imaginémonos sumergidos en
el gran alcance y la magnitud de todo esto.
Ahora, preguntémonos:
"¿Qué tan grande es?
¿Qué tan grande es el océano?"
Primero, tenemos que entender
que en realidad hay solo un océano,
compuesto por 5 cuencas llamadas
Pacífico,
Atlántico,
Índico,
Ártico,
y Antártico.
Cada uno de las 5 cuencas
si bien se conocen como océanos
en sí mismos,
en realidad son parte
de una única y enorme masa de agua,
un océano,
que define la propia cara
del planeta Tierra.
El océano cubre cerca del 71 %
de la superficie del planeta,
unos 360 millones de kilómetros cuadrados,
un área que excede el tamaño
de 36 veces EE.UU.
Es una extensión tan vasta que,
vista desde el espacio,
es la característica principal del planeta.
Hablando del espacio,
el océano tiene actualmente
más de 1300 millones,
miles de millones,
de kilómetros cúbicos de agua.
Dicho de otra forma,
es suficiente agua como para sumergir
a todos los Estados Unidos
en una masa de agua salada
de más de 132 kilómetros de alto,
una altura mucho mayor que
la de las nubes más altas
que se extiende en lo profundo
de la atmósfera superior.
Con todo ese volumen,
el océano representa el 97 %
del contenido total del agua de la Tierra.
Aparte de todo eso,
el océano contiene más del 99 %
de la biosfera del mundo,
o sea, los espacios y lugares
en los que existe vida.
Dejemos eso por un momento.
El mundo inmediato tal como lo conocemos,
la totalidad de todo el espacio viviente
comprendido por los propios continentes,
todo eso representa solo el 1 % de la biosfera.
¡El uno porciento!
El océano es todo lo demás.
Es físicamente enorme.
Su importancia para la vida
es prácticamente inigualable.
Contiene también
las mayores características
geológicas del planeta.
Rápidamente, aquí están
4 de las más notables.
El océano tiene la cadena montañosa
más grande del mundo:
la dorsal oceánica.
Con más de 65 000 kilómetros de largo,
esta cordillera subacuática es unas 10 veces
más larga que la cadena montañosa más larga
de tierra firme: los Andes.
Bajo el estrecho de Dinamarca existe
la catarata más grande del mundo.
Esta catarata enorme ve pasar unas 116 veces
más agua por segundo por su filo
que las cataratas Inga del Río Congo,
la cascada más grande de la tierra en volumen.
La montaña más alta del mundo se encuentra
realmente en el océano,
oculta a plena vista.
Mientras que el Mauna Kea
de Hawái tiene 4200 metros
sobre el nivel del mar,
sus laderas se desploman bajo las olas
otros 5800 metros.
Desde su cima cubierta de nieve
hasta su fondo cubierto de limo,
esta montaña hawaiana es de
unos 10 000 metros de altura;
sobrepasa a la minúscula cima del Everest
en más de un kilómetro.
Entonces, ya que estamos mofándonos
del pobre Everest,
consideremos el cañón más profundo del mundo,
la fosa de Challenger,
a 11 kilómetros bajo la superficie del océano,
unas 6 veces más profundo que el Gran Cañón.
Eso es suficientemente profundo como
para hundir al Monte Everest
en más de 2,1 kilómetros de agua
encima de su pico recientemente sumergido.
Dicho de otra manera,
la profundidad de la fosa de Challenger
tiene más o menos la misma altura
a la que vuelan los aviones comerciales.
Sin importar cómo lo analicemos
el océano es GI-
GAN-
TE.
¡GIGANTE!
Caracteriza al planeta,
hogar de las mayores características geológicas,
comprende el mayor espacio de vida,
y, en consecuencia,
es el hogar de la mayor cantidad
y las formas de vida de la Tierra.
Es prácticamente incomprensible en su alcance.
Pero no es tan grande,
ni tan vasto,
ni tan extraordinario,
como para ser intocable.
De hecho, con cerca del 50 %
de la población mundial
que vive a 100 kilómetros de la costa
y la mayor parte del resto
que vive cerca de lagos, ríos o pantanos,
y en última instancia conducen al océano,
prácticamente cada persona del planeta
tiene la oportunidad de influir en la salud general
y en la naturaleza de los océanos del mundo.
Se ve evidencia de la influencia humana
en todo el océano,
sin importar la profundidad
ni la distancia.
El océano define al planeta,
pero, en un sentido muy real,
nosotros definimos el océano.